hitting snooze will give you extra
meaningful rest hitting the snooze bar
is one of the worst things you can do
sleeping positions don't matter
now wrong sleeping positions absolutely
do matter if you snore you have sleep
apnea this one is critically important
to our sleep physician hi my name is
johar denjongui i'm a professor of
psychiatry and behavioral sciences and
my work focuses primarily on circadian
and sleep health and i'm rebecca robbins
i'm an instructor in medicine at harvard
medical school an associate scientist at
the brigham and women's hospital in my
research i designed behavioral
interventions to give individuals the
tools to improve their sleep and their
health and today we're making an effort
to debunk some common myths about sleep
it's better to be a morning person than
a night owl so one isn't better than the
other we do have in our society both
night owls and locks there's no question
about that
both of them do very well in terms of
their own personal livelihood the
difference is that for a person who
happens to be a morning person
because of their society structure they
tend to do much better we have sayings
like the early bird gets the worm and
unfortunately that's to the detriment
often of evening people they really live
in a morning person's world and often
are forced to work on a morning person's
schedule so what we hope to see happen
is that people become aware of the kind
of person they are if you happen to be a
morning person do know that your
performance is going to be much better
in the morning if you're an evening
person your performance is going to be
much better during the evening hours
sleeping positions don't matter
now wrong sleeping positions absolutely
do matter we all believe it or not spend
most of our time in one of three
positions most people are side sleepers
the next most common is your back and
the least common is sleeping on your
stomach the key thing when it comes to
sleeping positions is to make sure that
your spinal column is aligned and you
are supported over the course of your
sleep at night in your preferred
position i would only add that if you
happen to be somebody who has positional
sleep apnea the position in which you
sleep does matter because if you are
sleeping in a supine position it's more
difficult for you to breathe therefore
you snore a little louder and your bed
partner may not really appreciate that
now pregnancy is a time where your
sleeping positions also really matter
during pregnancy you want to make sure
you're comfortable and ideally on your
side so that the belly isn't compressing
down on top of you and the baby's
protected but the key thing for pregnant
people is you want to be comfortable in
whatever position you take make sure
that you are supported with lots of cozy
pillows the q4 jet lag is not sleeping
all night one of the common things that
we hear people say is often you know
i'll just stay up all night and i'll
cure jet lag and of course that's not a
cure for jet lag you're just sleep
depriving yourself so significantly that
of course you will fall asleep at any
time the next day there really is no
cure for a jet lag but you can cope with
some of the consequences by making sure
to walk outside in your new time zone as
much as possible get natural light
exposure if you're traveling east
do not wait until you get there and try
to
slip the part of yourself you can start
to prepare ahead of time so if you're
going to be going to paris you know it's
about five hours away so what do you do
you begin to shift your schedule
progressively maybe four or five days
before so that by the time you get to
paris you're already in the paris time
zone and try to avoid alcohol sometimes
that can interfere with your ability to
get healthy sleep avoid any type of
stimulant even if a few days you'll
adjust naturally hitting snooze will
give you extra meaningful rest this is
actually a myth hitting the snooze bar
is one of the worst things you can do
because what you're doing is you're
robbing yourself of some of the best
sleep in the second half of the night is
when we have most of our rapid eye
movement sleep and that's where we get a
lot of the benefits cognitively of our
sleep so if you're hitting your snooze
bar one or two or three or worse more
times you're interrupting some of that
really valuable sleep when it comes to
the standpoint of our cognition stiff
fragmentation is really not good because
it leads to all kinds of psychological
problem as well as physical problem if
you have stick fragmented then you are
more lucky to have cardiometabolic
dysfunctions and your mood is not as
positive as it should be instead of
hitting this news bar the best thing is
to sleep as late as you possibly can you
have to go to the office at eight
o'clock and it takes you an hour to get
ready set your alarm clock for seven
o'clock and commit to not snoozing get
up at seven o'clock and go about your
day so if you find yourself having a
heat distance button it tells you you
really need to have a
much longer period of sleep so you may
have to think about your lifestyle and
see how can you incorporate more sleep
in your daily routine
napping makes up for lack of sleep at
night napping is an interesting concept
in our field it does have its merit it
also has some of its drawbacks the ideal
duration for a nap is actually about 20
minutes so it's quite short so make sure
to set an alarm so you don't sleep too
long which will cause you to wake up
groggy and might affect your sleep that
night if you've already had your seven
hours which is your core sleep needs
there's no point trying to do more in
fact if you're trying to do more you
could develop insania because of that
taking melatonin will make you fall
asleep immediately it's not going to be
something that knocks you out right away
melatonin we call it a neurotransmitter
it's secreted in the brain it's
associated with the transition to
darkness in our environment and ideally
melatonin is a naturally occurring
process
but melatonin can also be taken
exogenously or as a supplement if you're
taking short active melatonin substances
it's highly recommended you do that
about two to four hours before bedtime
certainly not right before you go to bed
it takes a while before it becomes
effective most of the melatonin that's
available over the counter isn't highly
regulated so unfortunately we don't know
its purity the other key thing is many
people take far too much so often you go
to the drugstore and you see 10
milligrams 20 milligrams of melatonin
that's far far too much much smaller
doses are important you really want to
talk to your physician make sure that
you pick the right type of melatonin for
the problem that you're having if you
pull an all-nighter sleep as soon as
possible now hopefully you're not
pulling all-nighters because again sleep
is so important night in and night out
but if you did get a night of either
very insufficient sleep or maybe no
sleep at all this is a myth in some ways
because we don't want to just binge
sleep as soon as you're absolutely able
to what you want to do is actually get
back to your normal routine as fast as
possible so that means maybe trying to
push through the day and wait until your
regular bedtime maybe taking a nap in
the afternoon if you're tired but trying
to get back on your normal schedule as
soon as possible not necessarily sleep
as soon as possible that's an excellent
point i would only add that if you
happen to be a young person
that's really true a couple of days
before you're back on schedule if you
happen to be an older person in your 60s
and 70s it could take you up to a week
to recover so you have to think about
what am i doing do i have to do that
because there's a price to pay
particularly if you happen to be an
older person dreams only last for a few
seconds now dreams don't only last for a
couple seconds they can be a couple
seconds they can be a couple minutes and
they can be longer we all dreamed four
to five times a night and it happens
predominantly in rapid eye movement
sleep we believe about eighty percent of
dreaming takes place then you could have
a dream episode that lasts about five
seconds
and when you're recounting who actually
took place during the night you feel as
if you had this dream for like two three
hours you could also have a dream that
lasted ten minutes and then you feel it
really should have been about five
seconds it has to do with the emotional
content of the dream and in fact most
people remember their dreams because of
the things that they see if you see the
loved one
die in a car accident you're going to
remember this there's no precise
duration of dreams we know less about
their kind of quantity and and length
but what we do encourage is to have fun
with your dreams talk to a loved one
maybe keep a dream journal if you snore
you have sleep apnea now snoring is one
of the most common symptoms of a
condition called obstructive sleep apnea
which is life-threatening but the
snoring doesn't necessarily mean that
you absolutely have this condition many
people snore and are completely healthy
so essentially snoring osteopathic is
really a mechanical problem that is
because of the excess suede on the upper
airway you put too much pressure on your
throat therefore the airway collapses
either fully or partially that's what
snoring really is it's you making effort
trying to keep the upper airway open but
if that snoring is coupled with
excessive daytime sleepiness or if
you've ever been told that you wake up
over the course of the night or stop
breathing or gasp for air those could be
signs of sleep apnea sleep apnea is a
very serious problem some people can
actually die in their sleep this one is
critically important to our sleep
physician we do not want one more person
to die of a heart attack or a stroke
because of a problem they could have
fixed so you really have to understand
if that cardinal symptom of snowing
shows up
talk to a physician and make sure that
you don't have sleep apnea and if you do
we can actually help you breathe better
sleep better therefore have a very
productive and long life
insomnia means you can't fall asleep
it's
partly true partly not so true if you
happen to be somebody we can't fall
asleep fast enough then you have what we
call sleep onset insomnia which is true
but you also have the other one which is
that you fall asleep okay but you wake
up multiple times where the nanny can
you cannot go back to sleep that's the
main insomnia now insomnia is best
treated with a healthcare provider and
there are pharmacological treatments but
they're actually behavioral treatments
that are incredibly effective and that's
called cognitive behavioral therapy for
insomnia so if you're not sure what to
do we could contact with civilization
they'll be able to guide you if you
can't fall asleep anywhere and at any
time it means you're a good sleeper now
this most definitely is a myth believe
it or not it actually takes time to fall
asleep the hallmark of a healthy sleeper
is actually what we call sleep latency
or the time it takes you to fall asleep
of about 15 or 20 minutes if you're
falling asleep right away it generally
is a sign that you're not getting enough
sleep a good sleeper really is a person
we can function throughout the day
not falling asleep and inappropriate
circumstances most people need about
seven to eight hours of function
optimally but the fact that somebody
might be a short sleeper five six hours
if they're functioning absolutely during
the day they can go home and spend time
with the family walk the dog play with
the cat
then that person is a good sleeper but
if you find that you're sleeping five
hours when you're at work you fall
asleep you can't function properly your
mood is not what it's supposed to be
then you need to get a bit more sleep
more sleep is always better now this is
a myth more sleep is not always better
because in addition to getting
sufficient duration when it comes to
sleep consistency is critical so if you
look at maybe sleeping in or extending
your regular sleep times well beyond
what you typically keep then that's
going to throw your internal biological
or circadian rhythm completely out of
whack so instead of sleeping in on the
weekends or maybe binge sleeping the
ideal thing is to get onto a schedule
and try to keep it as close to monday
through monday as possible what we don't
want people to do is to feel i have to
sleep eight hours if you're
physiological for seven
then that's perfectly fine if it's sick
that's perfectly fine the question is is
it optimal for you
nightmares and night terrors are the
same now these two things are distinct a
nightmare is of course a disturbing
dream and a night terror is actually
something that we call a parasomnia
which refers to
abnormal behavior that occurs during
sleep but it largely happens in children
and does generally go away around
puberty now there are similarities with
these two things but the one difference
is that a night terror can be very
disturbing for the person who isn't
sleeping to observe in a sleeper anyone
experiencing night terrors is thrashing
about violently and so it can be a
little bit disturbing to watch
nightmares tend to be
a resultant of things you have been
exposed to during the day
if you had watch a horror movie some of
those meditations can carry on during
the night episode if you happen to be
under significant stress you're not
doing so well at work all of those can
cause nightmares one exception is the
environment we find experimentally when
we manipulate the temperature so we put
sleepers under a heat blanket so we can
make sure that they're nice and toasty
we actually see that their sleep
fragmentation increases and the reports
of nightmares as well so make sure that
your bedroom is on the cooler side we
generally recommend about 68 degrees
fahrenheit for an optimal sleeping
temperature those sleep means we talk
about maybe there are more but at least
for now we know these are the ones that
are counterproductive to our health and
well-being let's all have a good night's
sleep are we ready
all
right you've got to pull it off
should we eat both do you want some of
these